So we want the understand
defraction patterns.
It's clear that there's some relationship
between the arrangement of the
electrons that are doing the scattering
and the pattern of the scattery you get
right at a particular angle.
There's a particular intensity
and it must be depend on how,
it must depend on how those
electrons are arranged.
But how is the interesting question,
right?
So what we're going to do now is
look just a little bit at the,
no one figures this out.
In a real case,
people have written fancy
computer programs to do this,
but so that it doesn't seem mysterious.
I want you to get the
idea of how it works.
Okay,
so the first slide we showed,
or the third slide actually that we
showed last time was made of a bunch of
these things we call benzenes.
That collections are six dots
and they're simple.
They're already all oriented the same way.
That's not very reasonable except
when they get regular and a crystal,
which is where we're going.
But anyhow,
if you have a whole bunch of
them but randomly distributed,
it turns out the intensity you get is
stronger proportional to the number of
them that are doing the scattering.
Right?
But the pattern you get is the
same you'd get from just one.
So that's why we use this funny slide
and this was the pattern that came out,
this thing that looked a
little bit like a snowflake.
And I'd like you to understand why
that hexagon a dots gives a snowflake.
So we take the hexagon or dots and what
do we look for to see where scattering
might be to see what, what's
the number, what the trick is.
The trick is to look at things
that lie on equally spaced planes.
Try to choose a set of planes so that as
many of the electrons as there are will
fall on or near that set of
evenly spaced planes. Right?
So [inaudible] this is two dimensions.
So we're looking for lines or
cross sections of planes, right?
So how,
how could we draw lines on here evenly
spaced lines so that all the dots will
fall on them? Well, we could do
it that, uh, this way, right?
So they're evenly spaced,
three of them and all the
electrons fall on or near them.
Notice they don't have to fall exactly on,
cause if they're displaced a little bit,
the phase of the wave will change a
little bit compared to the others,
but only a little bit. So it just has
to be near not exactly on. Okay. So,
uh,
there we have it now.
So that means that you'll get scattering
in that direction where all there well,
where they will reinforce one
another. Right. Let's, uh,
let's go back to the,
to the display we were looking at before.
Ah, here. Okay.
We were talking about this just as
class started. So a wave comes in,
makes these things all move up and down
the electrons here and here at the same
time. Actually let's make all three
of them vibrate for current purposes.
Okay.
Now we're interested in what angles light
can come out and all these things will
help each other out reinforce one another.
So as we go here that and
look at that vertical line,
we see that they're not all in phase at
that angle, but as we increase the angle,
when we get to say here,
it looks not so bad. The top and the
bottom are actually exactly in phase,
but the middle one is exactly out of
phase and it'll cancel out the top one.
And if there were a whole
row of these, the the, the,
the second one cancels the first,
the fourth would cancel the third,
the sixth would cancel
the fifth and so on.
There wouldn't be anything coming out.
And now we go a little bit away from that.
And it's worth making a point here.
Suppose that this were a very, very,
very long line of scatterers.
Right? And the first two, let's,
let's get to this place here where
they're all exactly in phase,
that'll obviously very,
very strong angle.
But suppose we looked at another
angle that was close to that.
Just that just a teeny bit off.
So the first two are off by just,
you know,
one degree in phase and the next
one's off by two degrees in phase,
not much off.
Okay.
So are we going to get pretty
strong light coming out from that
Russell?
If it's a very long string,
if the first one's one degree out,
by the time we get to the hundred 80th
it'll be 180 degrees out or exactly 180th
we'll cancel the first one 181st
we'll cancel the second 183rd second,
we'll cancel a hundred we'll
cancel the third and so on. Right.
So it has to,
if you have a really long string,
it has to be exactly on from one to the
next in order to get them so that you
get something coming out
and what you get coming out.
Then we'll be quite strong because
there'll be the scattering from the whole
bunch of them.
Right.
Where does that, where did you
see that in last week's lecture?
Friday's lecture.
Right.
You saw it that you got very fine dots
when you had a really long row of things.
Okay,
so back to here.
Uh,
so there'll be things that are almost
exactly in phase and it'll be a certain
angle at which there'll be in phase
in that angle is shown by that,
the end of that Arrow.
And you get therefore a dot there.
And also by symmetry,
the other five of the six dots
as you could draw the lines,
other angles at the same way.
Everybody with me on that? Okay?
Okay. Now, uh,
so we look for electron density
on or near evenly spaced planes.
Now because it only has to be near, there
are other directions we could draw it.
So we get a set of planes where there
near but not on like here right now,
one is a little above the plane too,
or a little below the plane, right?
Or vice versa for the second line.
Right.
But they're pretty close and
there are certain spacing.
Now that spacing is larger
than the blue spacing.
Does everybody see that?
What does that mean?
About the angle at which the reflection
will occur or the scattering where
there'll be in phase,
the angle will be smaller.
So the, the part of the snowflake
that comes from that is here,
right?
Smaller angle because it's a larger
distance and you could see immediately why
that is. If we look at this
thing that, that if there,
if you look at the top to the
bottom where they're far apart,
the lines are far apart.
You get the first reflection there.
But if the line, but if the lines
are closer together, like these two,
then you have to go to a higher angle
in order to get that first one first
coming into phase,
right?
So that's that reciprocal relationship.
Okay.
So we get a set of six dots like that.
And that's most of the pattern.
But there are other places too.
You can see it, for example,
you can take those lines
in that set of lines.
Every, uh, every dot. The
center of every.is on a line.
There happens to be aligned in the middle.
That doesn't have anything on it.
But who cares, right? The others
are on evenly spaced lines,
right? So they'll all be in
phase where we'll that one km,
that reflection close in or far out,
far out.
And there you see it way out at the edge.
Can you see it there?
Just a little bit with the,
I can turn the room lights down
but I don't think it's worth it.
You can see that it's there and there.
And so there's six of them
out there as well. Okay,
so you got the idea of how by
looking for evenly spaced planes,
you can,
uh,
you can predict what the pattern will be
for a certain arrangement of electrons.
Now don't notice those
ones far out are very weak.
That's because although the centers
of the dots lie ride on the lines,
the lines are getting so closely spaced
that there's part of the electron
density that's not write the lines.
That in fact gets out to almost
halfway between the lines,
right at that part of the electron
density will be canceling.
So most of the electron
density is all in phase here,
but some of it is out of phase.
And as you get the lines
closer and closer together,
the fact that the electron distribution
is finite and not tiny points means that
things will get weaker and weaker
as you go to higher angles.
Okay, so there, there again,
we notice here that the closer
spaced planes you have higher angles.
This is what we've just
been talking about. Now,
when you take a slide with a
regular lattice of these benzenes,
then if you remember, if you took just
one, you get this snowflake pattern.
If you take a whole row across the top
right like that,
oh, pardon me, I meant to say that one
will be very weak. You can hardly see it.
What you need is a bunch
of them to cooperate to see
something that you can see.
Now first we could take
the whole row along the top
and and we're going to look only at
scattering in the vertical direction.
So I've narrowed in on the picture.
But if we take that
whole row along the top,
remember they'll all scatter in phase
at the specular angle because for go for
scattering up and down.
So now it gets more intense because
they're all cooperating for other
directions. They wouldn't all be in
phase from one hexagon to the next,
but for scattering up and down where
they're all at exactly the same level,
they'll all be exactly the same.
Okay.
Now suppose I had the next row.
Will they be in phase?
Well,
the second for the same scan for the
same direction of scattering up and down
where that top row is all in phase.
So we would get the
scattering shown here right?
Stronger than it was before because
it's a bunch of these things now. Right,
but still not really strong.
But let's add in the next row.
Is that going to make them
all stronger again? No.
Most of the time they'll be out of phase
from the next row for scattering in
this direction. Right. Most of
the time there'll be out of phase,
but for particular angles
there'll be in phase. So in fact,
what that will do if we
add the next row that we,
we made the picture of brighter,
cause we got twice as many
things scattering now,
but there'll be bars across it like that.
It's always the same pattern getting
brighter and brighter as we add more of
them, but at certain angles that are
in phase now and at certain angles,
they're out of phase from one pattern
to the next or from one row to the next.
Now, so what's going to, if we add
the whole sheet of them, can you see
Sam?
Ah,
they'll only be really precise
angles at which they all interfere.
Otherwise the hundred 80th will interfere
with the first 181st with the second
and so on, right? So if we add
the whole phase, the whole thing,
then if we look at the pattern,
it's going to be brighter, right?
But it'll be only at knots,
holy at very precise angles,
right?
And that's what we saw when we went to
this final picture for scattering from a
lattice.
So what this means is that the lattice
repeat concentrates the snowflakes
scattering into tightly focused
spots on a regular pattern,
right?
So this is the diffraction from
a two D lattice of Benzenes,
which is the same as the underlying
snowflake that came from just one.
But it's as if it were being viewed,
as I said last time through a peg board,
right?
All that scattering gets concentrated
into a few points. Very Bright.
And these are these regular points.
Now,
some people seemed not to
know what a pegboard was.
So I took a picture of a
pegboard over the weekend.
How many people have never seen a
pegboard before? Just to calibrate me?
Okay? Most people have seen
a pegboard, but you know,
you put it that you could put these hooks
in it and then hang whatever you want
on it, like tools or pictures or
whatever you want to put on your wall.
So it's like looking through the holes
in that at the snowflake pattern.
Now there's there two quotes,
spaces that get talked about direct space
or real space and diffraction space or
reciprocal space.
Okay.
So the crystal is the real
thing that you're interested in.
And diffraction photo
is in diffraction space.
You see these dots that allow, we
saw for example, for copper sulfate,
right? So in real space you
have a unit cell structure.
That is the thing, the pattern that
then gets repeated to make the crystal,
but you have the pattern,
right?
And that gives rise to this fuzzy pattern
like a snowflake and reciprocal space.
And then you have a crystal lattice or
regular repetition of these patterns,
right? And that's as viewing
through the holes in the pegboard.
Okay?
And remember that decreased spacing
and real space corresponds to increased
spacing and reciprocal space, which is
of course why it's called reciprocal.
Okay? So that's what we want to
understand about how it works, right?
There are patterns which give rise
to patterns and reciprocal space,
that buzzy thing. And then if you
have a repeating lattice of that,
it gets concentrated
into particular points,
but it's the same underlying pattern.
So there's the pattern,
which is the structure of the molecule,
and there's the lattice,
which is the structure of the crystal.
Okay.
Now let's look at the light bulb filament,
the last thing we looked at and see why
the scattering from that looks the way
we do it looks like this x with,
with dots along it.
Okay, so we take, we want to find if
there are electrons on this helix,
right?
We can find a set of evenly spaced
parallel planes like the yellow ones here.
So we'll get scattering
perpendicular to those planes.
And sure enough there it is that spot.
But we could also take a set of planes
and it goes not only up but also down
both branches,
but both directions of that particular
branch of the ex come from the same
planes.
Okay.
But you could make planes that are
twice as close to one another. Right.
What will those give rise to?
Twice as far out. The sign is twice as
big, actually. Not that actual spacing,
but it's, it's that one, the second
one out along the branch. Okay.
Now will that be,
do you expect that to be brighter
or not as bright as the first one?
Not Well,
uh,
there it probably will be not as bright.
And the reason is that for,
there are two things that have
to do with the brightness.
One is how much density there is on the
plains versus how much there is between
the planes,
right?
And we see here that say take the
original yellow one. There's a lot.
All of this stuff is nearly on the
plane and halfway between the plate and
there's not very much just a
thin cross section of the wire.
Okay? Uh, but as the planes
get closer and closer,
the fact that the wire has a
finite thicknesses thickness
means that some parts
of the wire, the same part of the wire
are out of phase compared to others.
So because of the finite thickness,
you expect it to slowly fall
off in intensity as you go out.
But you'll then get the third
one along the branch and so on,
and you can do the same trick
in the other direction, right?
So that's why it's an x. You can draw
this analogous mirror image lines.
Okay. Now what does the x,
the angle of the x tell you?
The x could look like this or
it could look like this, right?
What do you learn from that?
The angle that the x makes,
how tightly wound the helix is.
Cause if the helix, we're very right,
then the planes would be like this.
And if you'd grab the string and
the spring and stretched it out,
they'd look like this.
Right?
So the angle of the x tells
how tightly wound the helix is.
Tells the pitch of the Helix.
Okay.
What does the spacing
of the spots tell you?
Did you do the homework I suggested for
today that you didn't have to hand in?
Then you'll know what the
spacing of the spots tells you.
If you know the wavelength of the x
rays or of the light in this case,
what does the spacing
of the spots tell you?
Okay.
It tells you this how,
what?
The actual distance is between
successive turns of the Helix,
how far apart the planes are.
So it tells the scale of the Helix,
right?
The angle you get from the x,
but how big the actual helix is you
get from the spacing of those dots.
If you know the wavelength and the
distance that you're magnifying.
And in that case of the demonstration,
the distance from the slide at the back
of the room to the front of the room for
seeing this
and the spots weaken successively because
of y or thickness as we just explained
as you go on out.
Now that looks very much like a Rosalind
Franklin's B d n a photograph from
1952.
So we see the helix and
we see how how angled the,
the success of turns of the Helix are,
what the pitch of the Helix is,
and from the spacing of the dots,
we get how big the actual helix is.
But there's something funny,
it's the intensity doesn't just
evenly decrease as you go out.
It's instead of being strong,
not quite as strong,
less strong, weaker,
very weak. As you go out,
it goes weak, strong,
strong, very weak, strong.
Now why is that? Why do you get
such a funny pattern of intensities?
Let's look here at this uh,
thing again.
Remember where if we will look for
the first, second, third, and so on,
we saw that they come in and out of phase,
but let's suppose so it would be if
you have things that are twice as close
together here as in the first case,
what effect does that have
on the actual pattern?
We see the pattern we saw if we
had only every other one was here,
the direct beam. First
reflection, second reflection,
third reflection,
fourth reflection.
How does it differ if
we add one in between?
Okay, here's the first
reflection. Do we see that
if we have all three,
that's what
would've been the first reflection if
we didn't have the intermediate one.
Do we see a reflection here if
we have a whole row of them? No,
because every other one cancels
out so we won't see that one.
How about the next one?
Yeah, we very bright, right,
because there's more doing the scattering.
How about if we go to the next one?
No, nothing there. Cancel.
Right. How about the next one?
You perceive a pattern emerging.
What is it?
What
you see it and you don't see?
It.
Can you, can you say it in
a more mathematical way?
Suppose we numbered them.
The the one straight ahead. We'll call
zero. Then there'll be the first one, two,
three, four, five. What happens?
What do we put one in between?
Is One there.
This was one here,
right? There was one for the top and
bottom. Is that there? How about too?
How about three? No. How about for,
what's the, can you state at
mathematically Lexi, what do you say?
Can't hear it very well.
Which ones disappear?
The odd ones.
One, three, five, seven,
nine. The odd ones disappear,
but the even ones are still there,
right? If we put an extra one in between,
now let's think about DNA.
Here's a helix,
right? But what do you say
about DNA? Is it just the Helix?
It's a double helix. So there are two
heela sees. Okay, so suppose we have that.
They're the,
they're the success of turns and we
get scattering at a certain angle.
But suppose we make a double. He
likes now what'll happen, Lexi,
you're going to help me again.
How different will it
be if we have a second?
He licks wound halfway between the first,
he likes what will happen to
the what we are from one helix.
We had one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine with angles. Right.
What happens now?
Can't hear
all the arguments disappear.
Right?
So what would you have expected to see
in Rosalind Franklin's picture then?
Right. It would be weak. Strong,
weak, strong, weak. Strong.
Right.
But generally getting weaker as you go
out because of the finite thickness of
the wire. Is that what we see? No,
we saw the first one is very weak.
Strong,
strong, very weak. Strong.
Can you see any, how could
that be? What is that you?
Yeah, perfectly in face. What do you
mean they're not perfectly in phase?
There may be they're not equally.
Ah,
maybe the second one isn't
half way between the first.
The turns of the first
one. Right. What happens?
So the planes are twice as close there
and that would cancel every other
reflection. All the odd winds.
But suppose it's like that.
Did you ever see a
situation like that before?
Where what repeats is not
aligned but a pair of lines.
Angela,
the second diffraction pattern
we looked at was of that sort,
which showed the same dots,
but the intensity got modulated.
Remember?
Okay,
so let's instead of doing this
where we have equally spaced ones,
let's do one where
they're not equally spaced
like this. Now, oops, came loose here.
Uh, here we go. Oh No.
There we go.
Okay, now consider the top
and the bottom one, right,
which are in successive turns the same
helix and the this one is offset in the
middle, but consider just the
top and the bottom one. Okay.
There's the first reflection, the
second reflection, the third reflection,
the fourth reflection. Everybody
see between the top and the bottom.
Now tell me what happens if,
if I had that other one offset this way.
How about the first reflection there?
Is that going to be strong? No,
because the this one is canceling it
and remember there's also one like this
below this one. Remember, it's a
really long row of these things,
so it gets almost perfectly canceled.
Not quite because it's not quite.
There would be exactly the minimum and
when the first and the third are in phase,
the second one is not exactly out
of phase, but very close. Very weak.
That reflection's going to be.
Now let's go to the two.
What would be the second reflection of
the single helix there? How about there?
Yeah, the second one now is helping out a
little bit. Not Perfectly, but it's hell.
In fact, probably if you go just a little
bit further, maybe there'd be better.
But anyhow, there'll be
a reflection there. Okay.
Now how about if we go to the third?
That's as good as the second one, right?
And how about if we go to the fourth,
who would the fourth if
they were evenly spaced,
what would you expect for the
fourth? Very strong. Right?
So let's go to the forest. One,
two, three, four. What should it be?
Really weak.
And how about the fifth?
That's precisely what she
saw, right? Weak, strong,
strong. Very weak. Strong. So that's much,
this is how much it's offset from the
center in order to get that sequence of
intensities.
Everybody with me on this?
Okay.
So that's that repeated pair pattern
that we saw before and there's there you
see that that the outer coil of the DNA,
which has phosphorous in it
with a lot of electrons, right?
That's very much like this.
Like this helix. Okay.
Is much more electron density near
these planes than between them.
Then halfway between,
but there's also much more electron
density on those near those blue plains.
Then in between for the same reason.
And that means that you
get those spots on the side
that tells you the diameter or the helix.
Okay.
And the things top and bottom tell
you the base stacking distance.
Let me back up just a second to
show you what we mean, right?
So there are a bunch of electrons here,
bunch of electrons here, lunch here,
bunch here, and that gives
scattering in this direction.
So all that information, the helix
diameter, the fact that it's a helix,
the fact that it's a double helix,
the fact that it's an offset double helix
and the diameter of this cylinder are
all easily read out if you
know what you're looking for.
Which crick knew because he had been
studying Heela sees of proteins,
right? So he knew about, he knew
from helix scattering. Okay,
so knowing the molecules,
electron density,
as we knew our artificial
sort of benzene or this DNA,
it's easy to calculate the
crystals diffraction pattern,
especially if you have a
computer to help you out.
But it's not an intellectual
challenge. It's just work. Right?
Using pretty heavy duty math people got
the Nobel prize for developing it or,
or a canned program.
That's what they got the Nobel prize for.
You can go the other way and go from the
ex-ray pattern to what it was that was
causing it. Right. What we did was go
from what's causing it to the pattern now,
but in fact you can go the other way
now when you press a button on a machine
and you get out the electron
density at every point in space,
okay, that's the, that's the
yield from an x ray structure.
Why don't you get the nuclear positions?
Why do you get the electron positions?
Alex can't hear. It's too, it's too heavy.
So it doesn't vibrate the nuclei.
So they don't function as an antenna
to give off the new waves the way the
electrons do. Okay. So you get a
result, which you can plot on a map.
Now in the olden days when I
started doing this kind of thing,
the kind of map you got out was a big
sheet of computer output paper and it had
numbers it and it that a given piece of
paper was a given slice through the unit
cell through the pattern, right? And
numbers were printed out that said,
what was the electron density at
that particular point on that level.
So you know, you had
uh, uh, x axis, y axis,
and at this point it was 75,
40 to 55,
87 or whatever the number is and so on.
And what you do is take a felt tip
pen and co connect dots of equal size,
right? And you'd get a contour of
that particular electron density.
And here's where that was done
for a particular compound.
This is taken from a book written at
that time by stout and Jensen. Uh,
and you drew these by hand because you
didn't have a computer that could draw,
it, could figure out where
to draw it and so on.
So here was here where Adam's in
a particular crystal structure.
Now that Pr,
then you had a whole bunch of sheets of
paper for different slices through the
electron density.
Stack them up right now sometimes the
particular slice you're working in went
right through the middle of an atom.
So you've got very high electron density.
Sometime had just barely touched the atom,
right?
So you see here that that one,
that Adam,
this particular slice was very near the
nucleus. So we got high electron density,
but that when the nucleus
was not in this plane,
so you just got a little glancing
blow at it, but you could make,
you could draw these things on acetate
or plastic sheets and stack them up,
right?
So this was the model made for the
first determination of the structure of
penicillin. In fact, the potassium,
salt of penicillin,
where's the potassium,
Adam?
How can you distinguish potassium from
nitrogen or carbon or hydrogen or oxygen?
It'll have a lot more electron
density. So you see it, all right?
There's the potassium,
lots of density, okay?
Now here's a molecule
that happened to be flat.
So it was possible to slice
through practically all the nuclei.
It's not a very common type of molecule,
but this one is Rubo few, Seren,
okay?
Now these contours are drawn at intervals
of one electron per cubic Kang strum,
right? So the first one is
one electron cubic Galveston,
two electrons per cubic costume, three
electrons per cubic instruments. So on.
Now there are both carbons
and oxygens in this.
How can you tell which ones are oxygen's?
Yeah,
you in June,
they should have more contour lines.
So if we look here,
we see that that one goes up to five
electrons per cubic construct. One, two,
three, four, five rings, right?
That one goes up to seven electrons
per cubic Armstrong. And so do those,
right?
So those are the oxygen's.
Go ahead and there's a picture of
the structure and you see indeed,
those atoms are oxygens.
All right? Now, uh,
what is our fundamental goal
of looking at this stuff?
What do we want to see bonds?
Do you see bonds?
What does it look like?
It looks like just a bunch of balls.
Just Adams. But there was Louis, right?
Are there electron pairs but
halfway between the bonded
Adams?
No,
it's just Adams.
Why are there no hydrogens?
Because they have hardly any electrons
compared to the others, right?
So they're very weak thing.
Okay.
Now those are bonds.
You can see I'm there.
Where did those lines come from?
Angela? Would you say somewhat
true that, yeah, your drone.
How did you know where to draw
the bonds? Connected, dawn,
you connect the centers of the rings,
right? Those are the bonds. Now,
how do you know what's the single bonds?
What's a double bond?
What's a triple bond?
Yes.
Do you notice in that you notice in the
structure here on the bottom right there
double bonds and single bonds.
How do I know which is which?
Is there any way annoying
knowing Elizabeth distance
between the distance noble
bonds or should be shorter than
saying hold bonds and in fact,
notice that that here we have
short, long, and intermediate.
Why Intermediate?
Why do I draw a dotted line there?
Because we have this love here,
residents,
right?
So they're one and a half bonds.
Okay? But fundamentally what
we see our spiritual Adams,
right? No bonds, no one
shared pairs on oxygen.
Just Adams.
So was Louis Way off base?
Yeah.
Actually you can see the bonds with X-ray,
but you don't look at total electron
density. The way we're looking at it,
what you look at his difference density.
You see how different is the picture?
I actually determine from what I would
have expected if they were truly spec
just spherical Adams undistorted.
How do you find,
how would you make such a map?
So you have these pieces of paper that
say how much the electron density would
be at all different points experimentally.
How much it is experimentally.
Now I want to see how different is that
from what if I just had spheres for the
atoms?
What would I do?
I have to find out what the
spheres would look like,
what density they would predict at all
these different points, and then do what?
Subtract. Right? So that's
the difference. Density.
Sometimes it's called
[inaudible] formation because
it's how much the electron
distribution gets deformed
when bonds get made.
Okay? So you take the observed
electron density, which is from Ray,
which is experimental,
and you subtract atomic electron density,
which you calculate somehow. You know
what's very cool? Adams would look like,
we'll get to that next, how you would
know what that is. But anyhow, you,
how do you know where to,
when you're going to do the subtraction,
you have to make sure you position the
atoms properly to be subtracted, right?
How do you know where to put them?
How do you know where to
put your spherical items? So
that just attracted, yeah,
you put it on the center of
those rings, right? Okay.
So let's look at a case like this.
This was done by laser Ovitz and
Ziva Bercovitch yell and uh, what,
how was 33 years ago?
So this is an interesting molecule
because it has lots of different kinds of
bonds in it. Single bonds,
double bonds, in fact,
three double bonds in a row.
And also benzene rings that
have these resident bonds. Okay?
So we're going to look first at
one of the benzene rings. Okay?
So this map that I'm showing you
here is a difference density map.
It's the total minus what
it would be for the atoms.
But notice what was subtracted is just
the carbon density didn't subtract
hydrogens. So let's look at
the features that are big here.
This is how the electron density changed
in forming the molecule from Adams.
Okay?
So first look up there.
There's some very dense contours
right in the middle up there.
And that's the hydrogen which
was not subtracted, right?
So it's the biggest game left in town
once you've subtracted the spherical
carbons. Okay? Uh, okay,
so that's,
and the,
the total amount of intensity
in that region is one electron,
which is what you expect.
But now the total amount of debt formation
density in this region where there's
a single carbon carbon bond
is only a 10th of an electron.
What would Lewis have said?
Two electrons.
It's a 10th of an electron. Okay,
now let's slice that and, and,
and, and within the carbon, carbon
bonds of the ring, the aromatic ones,
it's bigger.
Why bigger?
Cause it's partially double bond in
the resonance structures. Right? Okay.
So it's 0.2 electrons for
those ones in the ring.
Now let's slice it and turn it so we can
see it's cross section and it's round.
No surprise there.
But let's slice the ones
in the ring and turn them.
It's oval, not round. The
bonds are not round. Why?
Oh,
because they're partially made up of
these p orbitals that point in and out of
the ring. Distorted
from being round. Okay.
Now let's look at the double bonds that
are in the middle of this molecule.
Okay, first that one, we've
already seen that bond before.
That was 0.1 had around cross section.
But let's look at one of the double bonds.
Not Too surprisingly,
it has more electron deformation
density and at 0.2 right?
And the one in the middle
actually has 0.3. Now you might,
they're both double bonds. So
probably they look similar, right?
And in a sense they do.
If we slice the first one and turn it,
it's oval for the same reason as before.
There's a p orbital pointing in
and out of the, of the board,
and if we look at it below,
part of the bond is caused by overlapping
as we'll see of those p orbitals,
so it's got an oval up and down shape.
How about the next one?
If we slice it and turn it,
it's also oval in cross section,
but perpendicular.
All right.
What do you expect the next one
would look like? It's symmetrical.
It'll look like the first one again,
but here's something interesting.
That cross section of the middle one
showed the defamation due to the pink,
but not the defamation showed showing
due to those neighboring blue ones.
There's must be something different
about the interaction at the end and the
interaction in the middle.
Does everybody see that problem?
You might think the middle one would be
round or cloverleaf shaped, but it's not.
It's distorted in the in plane direction.
But to understand this,
you have to be patient.
Wait till next week or later this week
when we start getting into quantum
mechanics.
But notice that it's as if
the carbons form better bonds.
So the, the bonds from those central
carbons at the end go up and down,
but the ones in the middle are in plain.
Cool. Now, how many electrons
are other in a bond?
So here we're going to plot how many
electrons vertically and how long the bond
is, which is related to whether it's
single, double, triple. In fact,
a single bond is there a double bond
in a triple bond? Have those distances.
Now, if you, uh, and in fact you
could also do a one and a half, right?
Those bonds in the benzene ring.
Now what would you expect this to be?
How many electrons? If you were Louis,
how many electrons would you have
in a single bond to double bond?
Four, six, three.
One and a half.
Okay,
so there's what you would expect for the
plot if Louis was right, two, four, six.
Okay.
Now we can take this molecule that we
just looked at and see how much electron
density there is in each of those bonds.
And I've color coded it and
it looks pretty darn good.
Right?
Hurray for Lewis.
And in fact,
the people who did the work laser over
itch and bercovitch Yellen looked at a
bunch of other structures to and
added those to the same plot.
And they're not bad
except the scale is wrong.
Instead of being two four, six,
which I've fade it out here,
it's 0.1 0.2 0.3
so bonds are a very minor game
and the distribution of electrons,
Louis in a sense was sort of right.
There are,
is electron density shifted between the
atoms, the hold them together, right,
but much less than pairs of electrons.
In fact,
this amount of bonding density is about
one 20th of what Louis Bite of said,
but never did say because
he wasn't that naive. Okay.
So instead of getting to
you get a 20th of 2.1 okay.
So Bonnie density is about a
20th of a Louis. Incidentally,
the unit Lewis is used only
within this class. Okay.
So here's another example done by donuts
in Switzerland and these people who
were the uh, uh, Seiler and Shites
or who were, you know, Swiss,
who were the progeny of watchmakers
and people that do very precise work,
cause the do this,
you have to have really
precise experimental work
if you're going to subtract
something from something else and have
the difference be meaningful when the
numbers are almost precisely the same,
right?
Remember we looked at the total electron
density. You look just like spheres.
So you have to be really good with this
if you want to have this be meaningful.
And those guys are really good.
This was done what, 25 years ago.
Okay. So they took this molecule which
is highly symmetric, which is great.
Remember it's got its residents structure,
so all the bonds around the
middle or the same top and bottom.
Okay?
So we all,
we need only look at a quarter of
the molecule or for convenience,
a little bit more than a quarter.
So I'll blow it up here.
And there is the electron
difference density.
So this is how the electrons shifted
during formation of the bonds.
Okay, so there is a carbon, carbon
aromatic bond, a bond and a half.
And if you'd turn it and look at it,
it's the store did the way you expect.
Just as in the previous experiment
we talked about. Here's another one.
Same deal right now. Here
is a single bond. Carbon,
carbon single bond. What's it going
to look like in Cross section round?
Good.
Now here is a carbon nitrogen triple bond.
This is something new. What's it
gonna look like in Cross section?
Maybe like a cloverleaf,
Huh?
Like that?
It looks like that.
It's round. It's not cloverleaf
and it's not a diamond.
It's round in cross section,
so we'll address that later.
What's that? That's not a bond.
That's the unshared pair on nitrogen.
Well, what's special here?
What are we looking at?
We're looking at the
carbon fluorine bonds.
Does it look like the carbon
carbon bonds are carbon nitrogen?
How's it different?
There's no there. There,
right? There aren't any electrons
holding carbon to fluorine.
What the heck is going on?
Where is the CF bond?
This brings up the second
great question in the chorus.
What's the first question?
How do you know? Right.
And the second question is
illustrated by this. A film clip.
Oh, the sounds down. What
caused the sound to go down?
Huh?
See if that does it.
Come on,
baby.
I worked hard on this.
That sounds familiar though.
Can you
I find it before class.
Did you hear it?
Okay.
I'll tell you what it says.
Do what?
Let me try this just to make sure.
It's not that
I can do it myself.
This is a disaster.
Catch some thieves. Harmson that's
what we're here for, Mary. Well,
sir, click, click, click, click.
What do you think of him
compared with what sir? Exactly.
Okay.
What do you think of it
compared with what's are
exactly.
That's the second question
compared with what?
In anything quantitative.
Even many qualitative things.
That's the question and that's
where we're having problems here.
Looking for the CF bond.
We already saw this question
when we talked about resonance.
Remember I asserted that
when you have residents,
the molecule is unusually stable.
What should you have asked
compared to what? Right?
In that case,
it turns out it's compared to
observed or calculated energy.
Compare.
The observed are calculated energies.
What really happens to what you
would expect if it were not resonant.
And we'll talk later about how on what
basis you might have an expectation.
Now we're talking about difference
electron density. So what do we compare?
We compare experimental electron
density or it could be calculated,
right? Cause we, if we can use
quantum mechanics to calculate it,
but compare experimental electron density
to what? What have we compared it to
what it would be if it were just
Adams, right? But what kind of atoms,
right?
We compare the observed are calculated
total electron density to the sum of
electron densities for a set
of undistorted Adams. Now,
what's an undistorted Adam?
Okay.
Now to avoid Paoli problems,
and this isn't the time
to discuss what those are,
we need to subtract not an
unbiased spherical fluorine atom,
which if you count up how many
electrons there are on fluorine,
each quadrant of space around flury in
of which there will be for each quadrant,
we'll have one in three
quarters electrons in it, right?
You multiply that by four
and you get seven electrons,
which is the valence electrons
of, of, um, of fluorine,
right? But, uh, if you,
but you can't have one and three
quarters electrons from fluorine and also
electron from carbon in the same place,
that's too many electrons
in the same place, right?
So what you have to start with is not
an undistorted spherical fluorine atom,
but a fluorine atom that's
prepared to make a bond,
which has only one electron in the
region where it's gonna make a bond.
So if you subtract the spherical one,
you're subtracting too much from
the region of the bond, right?
So that's why you don't see any
electron density in there. So,
and if you want to understand this
better than I've explained it,
go on the web and look at Professor Dunn.
It's explaining it.
We have a little movie of him talking
about this particular problem, okay?
But at any rate,
the conclusion of all this is that bonding
density is about one 20th of a Louis,
right? And it's time for me to quit.
We'll go on with this next time.